honey what's wrong do you love me of
course we love you more than anything
and tell me the truth
I think the way Paige took the news was
exactly how Philip predicted which is
why I think predominantly for the
majority of the season he didn't want to
tell her you know you know it was
inevitable it would be cataclysmic in
her world for me when I first read the
script for that I was like so surprised
because I mean I was expecting it to be
like a huge thing like it was all
planned out and it was a big setup and
like they knew how they were gonna tell
her but at the way it happens is so
amazing and it's like so out of the blue
when no one's expecting it like they're
just standing in the kitchen so I mean
it's just like Family Talk
spies we serve our country but we also
serve the cause of peace around the
world we fight for people who can't
fight for themselves stop and I think
part of what was interesting to explore
this season is that in a way Paige knows
when she finally confronts her parents
she says come on you're out in the
middle you get calls you leave you
disappear what are you so in a way she
knows and one has to ask the question
setting aside to recruited her
he's a good for her to know where's
enough